so today's question comes from tracy in
connecticut she visits dave ramsey.com
to ask
six years ago six years ago
half a decade ago plus one while we were
going through a rough time my husband
and i moved into a property that belongs
to my parents and they have never
charged us rent over the last couple of
years i've been trying to convince my
husband that we need to move out
and rent somewhere since we aren't ready
to buy
he doesn't want to rent and would rather
stay here until we were able to buy
i'm afraid he's become comfortable with
our living arrangement you think
i feel like this arrangement is
hindering our ability to be mature
adults and i'm losing respect for myself
and my husband what should i do
how do i convince my husband that we
have overstayed when him
and my parents think this arrangement is
okay
there's so much here man break it down
there uh doctor so i'm gonna ask you
i'm gonna run you through some questions
like i would ask somebody if they just
plop this in front of me okay
all right question number one you have
lived rent free for six years
and you are still not in a position to
get your own place tell me about that
oh man number two
over the last couple of years you've
been trying to convince your husband
that you need to move out
how do you convince your hus like what
what is what's going on for
a couple of years that is not sinking in
right yeah
that you want to move out and rent
somewhere since you aren't ready to buy
number three he doesn't want to rent
he'd rather stay here until we were able
to buy
i understand that sentiment if you were
actually working towards getting ready
to buy right i understand the math part
of it there you go
that leads me to number i don't even
know number on number 41
right number four i'm afraid he's become
comfortable with our living arrangement
yes anytime you put somebody in a place
where they have no
rent no bills and they're just going to
be able to coast you are correct that is
a recipe for a comfortable living
arrangement
uh number five i feel like this
arrangement is hindering our ability to
be mature
adults and i'm losing respect for myself
and my husband
that's where i wanna park is taking a
rent-free arrangement from your in-laws
less mature less responsible
less respectful what do you think
anthony
i wish i could ask more questions right
because
there's so much there that i really want
to dive into one
why did you all go there in the
beginning um and then i'm like you
number two okay you all been there six
years and you're still not in a position
to do something are you not in a
position to purchase a home
or are you not in a position to even
move out
and again apartment and so for here
what i would recommend to her and again
i'm not married so i want to leave this
majority on you because i want to make
sure that you know i'm respecting
my lane that's a good pass you know as a
single person
um i want to make sure that them to
actually all of them all the parties the
in-laws the husband and her need to have
an honest conversation
and we need to come to an end date to
win okay
when will this partnership
end okay when are you all moving out
when are we moving out here's the date
and then from here moving forward uh the
wife and the husband
need to have a conversation all right
that's our date what are we doing to
meet that date and right now they're not
in a position to buy no home
no home we're going to rent all right
we're going to rent they should be in a
position
they should be debt-free to be honest
they should have no
no major bills because they they've been
living rent free for six months
six years six years i mean i keep saying
six months six years
oh man i wish y'all could just call into
the show i i really wish they could just
call into the show
if you're hearing us right now call into
the show the next time dr d
or myself or on because i have a lot of
questions i i
i want to focus on mature adults and
losing respect one of the cornerstones
of maturity to me is
this idea of intentionality yeah do you
have a plan yeah
i don't think it it immediately suggests
you aren't mature
if you are able to live rent free in an
in-law's
home um while you get your stuff
together i think the immaturity comes
though
six years later there's no plan yes
there's no objective there's no hey you
know we're gonna do this for seven years
and we're gonna pay
cash for our house and let's clear this
up we're not calling
them immature what we're saying the
decision that
that you've made over the last six years
sure is immature
and you're clearly not on the same page
with each other right right one of you
is losing respect for
for both of you you're trying to
convince one another like that's just
not how relationships work so
what should i do how do i convince my
husband that we have overstayed
it's very hard to convince somebody it's
very hard to convince a man let's just
be real
well ah that works both ways too men are
can be especially hard-headed but it
works both ways
i think the idea is to less try to
convince somebody try to quote unquote
change their mind
and really you need to get out of this
free house now again you're talking six
years this is a whole different level of
enmeshment
you need to get out of here and really
let him hear
not nagging not complaining not i'm
losing respect for you
but here is my vision for us yeah i want
us to have our own place
uh i want us to be together
and have shared goals that don't include
my parents
that include us working together and
moving forward and letting somebody hear
that that's different than
hey hey what about this what about this
what about this you disagree with me so
bring it back
yeah i don't know if i would say that
wife should come back and say here's the
vision that i have for us
here's another here's my dream yeah yeah
yeah that's all i gotta say because i
mean now some ladies may be like ah
anthony really but i think the vision
needs to come
from the both of you you co-create it
but it starts with one it starts with
one thing i want you to hear my heart
yes
and here's my passion here's my vision
for us and here's the deal
parents got tracy and her husband under
their thumb of course they're going to
be great with that arrangement
so the practical step here is first
thing is
pray ask god to give you the words and
the wisdom to have a conversation with
your husband have a conversation with
your husband
away from your in-laws after that
conversation you and the husband
come back sit down have a meeting with
the in-laws
and you all go from there got a dream
together